Oooh Oooh
Oh oh oh
It's just another night
Just another fight for my life
It's alright because everything dies
Nobody know why
What am I to do?
What is one to do?
When you feeling like you're falling
and you can't find nothing to hold on to
Memories oh carry me go
Carry me go oh nowhere
Sick and tired of it all
Take me far-away
Mr. DJ, take me high
Man can't trust anybody
that's why I can't shout
My body is tired
I've lost my composure
I'm losing my mind
God help me
My body is tired
I've lost my composure
When my whole world is set on fire
don't leave me alone
What am I to do?
What is one to do?
When you feeling like
you're screaming really loud
But nobody hears you
See it in your eyes
I see in your eyes
the betrayal and the lies
You've been pulling out knives
from your behind
Count every blessing
Count every lesson
It may not be here tomorrow
So I count every second
Don't let them take my head
And dance over my dead body eh
Body eh
I'm weak, I'm blind give me the strength
I need for my body eh
Body eh
My body is tired
I've lost my composure
When my whole world is set on fire
don't leave me alone
Don't leave me, don't leave me
Hold on
Don't let me go down, don't let me go down
So far, it is the memories I can see
They are taking me from reality
It doesn't require visa
I have been very quietly dying
And I need you to remind me why
Give me the strength to keep fighting
Cause I can't trust anybody
That's why I can't shout
My body is tired
I've lost my composure
I'm losing my mind
God help me
My body is tired
I've lost my composure
When my whole world is set on fire
don't leave me alone